hello hello
good to be here
on the stream forgot to turn on the
microphone this part is still wrinkled
it's a little better
uh my name is hans kim and i'm here on
the stream
let's get some high-res tacos in the
background
tools
size large
tacos
oh god just show me the image
and welcome to the stream we're here
live talking to the people
um my name is hans kim i am hanging out
having a good time
uh people are giving me advice in the
chat i love the advice keep it coming or
better yet do it yourself
um
wacko
i love wacko wacko taco
um
i think it's great that um
yesterday i was at the vulcan
uh did a little show with uh joe rogan
and tony hinchcliffe and brooke
kreischer pretty great show
this is my life now i just get to do
comedy shows with people that i
listen to
on podcasts and
you know like they're just celebrities
and now they're like actual people that
i can touch and
you know
assault i mean not assault i mean just
verbally assault
i mean emotionally maybe
um but yeah it's pretty crazy
ever been to wacko i've driven through
wacko
it's a pretty cool town
it's got a nice
highway town vibe
a lot of fast food there i'm sure a lot
of cool foods in wacko
um
but yeah i'm going to be in fort worth
i'm going to be in san antonio i'm going
to be in boston i'm going to be in
detroit this weekend with joe rogan and
then another time without joe rogan just
on my lonesome
um without my big old joe rogan to
protect me i'm going to be out there in
the world
um
i don't like tacos
honestly i'm more of a fan of burritos
because you get more slimy [ __ ] in there
i feel like the meat and tacos is a
little tough
um
and
you know it's spills all over the place
like a burrito it contains
all the yummy goodness and you can get
more refried beans in there which i love
not a real thing and with
tacos as much
you can get some rice in there some
cheese and
i just love this slimy messiness i like
refried beans
muskegon in michigan
i'm traveling all over the place i'm
going to
florida i think
i have a lot of a lot of plans a lot of
people hitting me up so i uh it's easy
to book [ __ ] now i'm going to seattle
soon
it's easy to book [ __ ] when you just
have to sit there and say yes or no but
it's not even that easy
because i'm lazy and i'm bad at stuff
and i don't know what i actually want
but if it's like a real comedy club and
the money's good then i'll be there but
i don't know like
i don't really want to do things that
aren't like real legit stuff because
then i might be in
muskegon michigan and like no there's no
hotel there's no car
and then i might get stuck there
i can't get stuck in michigan
dear hans kim your eyes are like two
tacos well
if you got tacos that were the size of
my eyes you'd probably be really mad
you'd probably demand
your money back
so
yes uh you can travel the world but you
can't run away from the person you are
in your heart
um
well what if you go to sleep or what if
you're in a coma dreamless sleep just
smoke a bunch of weed and sleep because
weed prevents you from sleeping
dreaming
akash thing will be i got ticks
whataburger overrated yay nay i mean i
don't think whataburger is very highly
rated to begin with so i think it's
rated correctly i mean it's all right
but i think it's like a little flat
i mean um
it's a soulless corporation that just
fully embraces the texasness so i don't
know if it can really
aspire to the level of artistry that you
need
to be good at food
to be good at foodstuffs
food is so tall food is so difficult
it's an art form and whatever
how tall is jogen
jogen is tall enough
if he was taller
it'd be a problem
because
then it'd be like wow he's even
more uh more of a presence and a
stronger
presence than he was before as if he
wasn't already
you know it's like
i mean height is a not a big deal how
big are your eyes without glasses the
same size as they are with glasses just
a little bit different there
how much does tony pay you
that is a question that i'm not going to
answer you conniving little shits
if you become joe if i become joe and
have whatever protection you want come
to see us we will be cool brother
yeah i mean i'd love to go i mean i if i
was joe's level then i wouldn't want to
go but since i'm my level and i'm tiny
and compact and maneuverable i'd love to
go to muskegon michigan or whatever
town you're in
um but yeah i mean why don't you go to
detroit akash will have zero issues
uh lamell what is your fav place to eat
in austin probably see them smokehouse
the brisket blue burger
um i mean the other places are good but
they're expensive like i'd love to eat a
terry blacks as much as i eat at cm
smokehouse but they're just like
prohibitively expensive it's more like a
little
uh
time it's like a
oh cool
i'm gonna do the thing i'm gonna do the
tourist thing go to see uh terry blacks
how good is your stand-up at the
beginning of your career it was about as
is like
my comedy now but like nine years
regressed
have you smoked the mt yet yeah i got a
little pen
they have little vape cartridges so you
can go
[ __ ] crazy you can just do it
conveniently at a moment's notice
um
i like hanging out um i like
going out but honestly i don't really
like talking to strangers that much
i mean i do like talking to some
strangers in very specific
interactions
and like getting to know people but i
feel like there's so much more depth and
um
there's more [ __ ] you can do with
someone that you know for a long time
and you develop a relationship with it's
like playing three on three basketball
versus five on five
with strangers that you don't know it's
just sort of like
who are you why am i talking with you
like what is the point of this like if
i'm not going to get something physical
or
[Music]
like a gift or like sex right away like
i i really don't want to be talking with
strangers
i'd rather be talking with someone that
i know and that i could do inside jokes
with and do like a lot of stuff
with instead of like
instead of like someone who's a stranger
who's like we're just gonna talk about
like basic [ __ ]
i'd rather like play off previous
statements and i'd rather play off our
relationship and be like yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna abandon you hahaha i'm gonna
say something racist now
um but yeah just like the stranger
conversation i think the metagame isn't
as advanced as with someone that you
know for a long time so i just i just
enjoy talking with people that i
actually know and can develop a
relationship with
um muskegon yeah i'd love to go go to
your town you know it's not like i have
anything against specific places in the
world i'd love to go everywhere it's
just like
what kind of infrastructure do you have
you know do you have public transit do
you have a airport that has
a lot of air travel through it so that i
can get a cheap flight does it have a
big enough population that i can milk
for money so i can buy a hotel
i mean it's not like i would
i would be better than any specific city
um i would love to go to any city it's
just like how convenient and easy for me
is it because i love being in austin i
got my tacos here
i got
i got my friends here i get booked here
pretty regularly i got a scene here that
i can ignore uh and just live by myself
i got a girlfriend here it's just
you gotta compete with that and it's not
like muskegon is like a terrible place
it might be who knows
but it it doesn't have my girlfriend it
doesn't have my
joe rogan daddy it doesn't have my
vulcan my kill tony it's just
this takes a lot to get out you know
sometimes you feel like getting out of
your town
now this town has been really good to me
not every town has been this good so
like right when i a town has been really
good to me and it's like [ __ ] amazing
that's when all the opportunities to
leave it arise
like back when i was in new york just
slumming it being miserable and getting
[ __ ] on by every open micro who
was like
advocating for the status quo and doing
knock knock jokes and puns and not
really contributing to the culture
then
no one wanted me and i wanted to leave
but when i love it here that's when
everyone wants me to leave here did you
do open mics while living in atl i
didn't do open mics while living in atl
i did open mics while i was traveling
through atl later on in my life as a
20 late 20 year old man
uh we have an airport there's no comedy
scene it's a beach town on lake michigan
well now is the perfect time to go to
muskegon
pops is like [ __ ] a tourist advocate
he's like working on the board of
tourism for muskegon he's really doing
muskegon a solid here for like the 30
people that are watching
25.
um
yeah you have an airport that's awesome
congratulations i don't have an airport
i barely have a house
how does it feel being surrounded by
people who are as popular as rogan and
tony you fit in with them which is
surprising how would you know i fit in
with them have you been there hanging
out with me in the green room when all
those famous people are there i get [ __ ]
on a lot and i get [ __ ] with and
bitched on and
vomited on
and i love it
i mean we're all getting gonna be [ __ ]
on i'd rather be [ __ ] on by
the best of the best their shits are
exquisite and ex
extremely awesome
do you listen to aphex twins no i don't
really know who afix twins are jo
william montgomery keeps making jokes
about them but it's weird it also
doesn't have the big red machine yeah
hey hans you're all right thanks james
watkins
you're alt-right
hans what are you smoking on nothing
right now
i'm completely sober so beer fo sobierto
do you think the perception of asian men
is improving these days yeah so it's
slowly improving we got some hunks out
there
slaying it
uh we got some big old men
mending around
um
uh
i think that um
asian men are the future like
if you want to live in a society
and a
uh civilized place you just gotta have
less body hair don't smell as much fit
in tight spaces
you've got to
uh not have outbursts of emotions you
gotta like keep it in and play your
cards right and
you can't just be
[ __ ] blah wow whoa look at that oh
wow i'm so [ __ ] hungry whoa what is
going on here you gotta be like oh yes
oh yes and you can navigate cities
better
which is good and bad you know i think
that there's a lot of beauty and art
inside the introverts mind that if you
can harness
it would be awesome i mean but asia is
coming from a pretty traumatic time
during world war ii and the japanese
occupation those [ __ ] japanese people
really [ __ ] us up
the japanese were like hey look we can
do imperialism just like the whites
and i think this is the thing everyone's
doing let's do it yeah
and then they [ __ ] destroyed asian
unity
and now
and they raped a bunch of people and
murdered them and destroyed cities and
stuff and culture
but you know it's not really their fault
they were
they had a really militaristic society
or whatever
and they got caught up in their own
[ __ ] once you have like a society
that's like
so excited about violence and [ __ ]
all that [ __ ]
and then uh then it's just it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy it's like a
positive or negative feedback loop it's
just i want to invade this and then they
start attacking each other and the
japanese army and the navy apparently
were very like argumentative and stuff
um and they were always fighting and
competing to see who had supremacy and
the whatever hans is there anything we
can do it as your fans that would help
you
get to your goals faster
yeah you can
give me money
i don't know how much that would help
i think what you could do is just
just act naturally you know don't
cuddle me but don't hate me
like
give me what you naturally authentically
feel like giving me and that'll be a
good indicator of whether i'm doing
correctly or incorrectly
um anything that's uh takes too much
effort don't do unless it's like giving
me free [ __ ] like someone gave me
a free vr set logan brent shout out
he lives in san antonio he's doing like
a crypto comedy club which i'm not a big
fan of cryptocurrency
right now in its current forum i think
it could be better but
um
i don't think in its current form it's
better any system where you have to
invest early on and hope it becomes
successful and risk losing your money
that doesn't seem like the future that
just seems like the same old [ __ ]
we've been doing
um but i like the idea of it and i think
eventually we should definitely evolve
into cryptocurrencies and get away from
[ __ ]
what was your first joke that killed the
room
um
hey look i'm asian i was in this asian
looking venue
and then i was like hey look it's i'm
asian hans i'm moving down to austin in
a van shortly i'm going to try comedy
what's your advice on that you're going
to try comedy
um
well do it respect the art form you know
put in a lot of effort and you'll go far
if you don't put in a lot of effort and
just want to get by on being arrogant
and egotistical then
comedy will chew you up and spit you out
it's a tough tough business when you're
throwing your brain out in front of
people and being like look what my brain
looks like this is what gives my brain
pleasure
do you like the things that give my
brain pleasure
people will be like no
that's gross ew i hate you
why did you think that would be
something suitable for us to watch
you're disgusting boo
so you know get ready for that if you
can handle that then you can try comedy
if you can handle being [ __ ] on and
regurgitated by society and people and
just being everyone hate you that's the
only way you can get that love that
you're seeking so much that you'd want
to try comedy
to be loved you must first be hated
you must face your worst fears to get
your wildest dreams
to come true
my girlfriend's italian she's a whitey
i got me a whitey
i'm doing good for the white cause
i'm [ __ ] one of you whites
now you know how i feel when one of you
are [ __ ] me
me peoples
um but yeah comedy's pretty brutal and
it's like intellectual pain and
emotional pain that's way more difficult
sometimes than a
physical pain
although physical pain can be pretty
brutal too
i've heard
you know like that constant uh pressure
or like torture
can be
[ __ ] awful everyone subjects submits
to torture there's no one who can
survive that [ __ ]
if you have someone tied up
there is literally nothing you can do
and you will eventually submit so
you know
it's like
yeah i don't know i think uh
i think torture is pretty horrible and
we should do our best to be kind to
people because we all have physical
limits but yeah i mean comedy pain is
pretty painful too it's the worst pain
you can go through legally like people
can [ __ ] on you and make your brain feel
awful and there's nothing you can do
i guess with emotional distress in
canada maybe you can
but
you know it's just whatever it's like
what you have to do
so
someone asked what did you think of
jacksonville willie g
i thought willie g jacksonville is a
great place a lot of great people i met
the mayor he had a broken arm for some
reason i met the governor right i mean i
saw him
ron desantis
i was in the room
during the ufc
where he was watching and then he came
out and everyone cheered for him but
yeah i mean i think jacksonville is a
cool town it's kind of got like a grungy
vibe people are like making it people
are like doing it
it's got like a little bit of a suburbs
vibe but i
think there's a lot of homeless people
too
there seems to be like an artistic vibe
to it too but i think honestly the
infrastructure
is dog [ __ ] everything is paved over and
it's like giant highways and parking
lots and you can't be a human you need a
car to get in it anywhere
which you know what i think about that
it's just not a good way to live as a
human being as a human being you should
really uh live in an area that is
designed for humans um but
other than this shitty car sprawl
suburban [ __ ] it's pretty good
uh hans
what does hans testify at the johnny
depp trial
i'd be like you know
i think that
people can be shitty
and i think
if men and women are shitty equally and
then one gender is considered to be
uh perfect and unable to cause any harm
then people are gonna
abuse that
to the same degree that um
you know like
if men and women are equal and men are
just as bad as women are then if you
give women this leeway to be like
you're
the best and no one can
uh doubt you and you're always right
then they're gonna use that and be
horrible people
and this is one instance where
this woman was horrible i think overall
women are less horrible than men
uh if that distinction is important you
know it's like it's not men that are
more shitty than women it's a human race
that is shitty and that shittiness
resides in men
and it's just the
um
meta game that we have to play like
men being shitty wouldn't exist without
women being complacent
and apathetic but um
yeah i mean if you want to boil it down
to a gender it's like
which
which part of your body is the mo does
the most evil oh it's my right hand it's
the one that stabs all the people and
shoots people well it needs
a whole
body to do all that [ __ ] so it doesn't
really matter
um which hand is specifically
responsible like we're a species and men
are an aspect of that species
and men are more evil than women but
we also invent more [ __ ] so
take the good with the bad it's like the
the species is evil and we need to
deal with the evil as a species and not
as a gender because
i mean as a gender it's so limited but
as a species you can get deeper down to
the root of the problem
it's easier to catch men than women
yeah i mean i think men are like maybe
55 percent
responsible for
the evil in a relationship in the world
i think it's a lot more but that's
because women
outsource their evil to men and then
they just sit around and take the good
parts of it which can make them more
evil like in
the south when white women would accuse
black men of crimes because they they're
like just floating by and they don't
have to do any work and they're like
lashing out because they have no
repercussions they're protected by men
from reality so they're there they have
to
they have to uh
they have to provide their own backlash
to uh their consequences to their
actions because it's not always matched
by reality
um so they they can be more evil but i
think overall men are more evil and so
this is kind of cool that a woman is
more evil than a man apparently that's
that seems to be the consensus
but i think uh it really doesn't matter
the gender like oh women are more evil a
woman is more evil than a man it's like
i i think that's the wrong level to get
in on this story yet
i think um
like
it's just interesting to see ego and
mania and relationships and people
fighting with each other and
you know like disagreements because we
all are in relationships with other
people and we all want to know how to
navigate that [ __ ]
and it's just cool to see that played
out on a grand scale where the the
weights are so much larger than our puny
little lives with their
non-consequential
choices
like they have
way more [ __ ] going on and there's way
more consequences to
amber heard saying johnny depp is an
abuser than like some random
jane shmayne
in maine
um
but why koreans have such a good skin
why food is love have such a bad grammar
um koreans have such a good skin because
we were designed to live in a society
and our skin is dry erased to make
ourselves clean
so that we don't get dirty and spread
diseases as much
we're all packed in there so the amount
of diseases we spread is pretty even but
we also don't live with our animals like
americans and europeans did with their
cattle
their chicken and all that i guess we do
in wet markets
but i think mostly asians were rice
farmers
and rice doesn't give you as many
diseases like smallpox and gonorrhea
um so i'm guessing that's why asians
have good skin it's because we're
designed to live in
packed environments and cities and be
civilized with each other and americans
and europeans are designed to
fight in the 100 year war and
man the
ramparts and
throw down oil on people
humans are the deadliest and most cruel
animal alive by far
practical paracord nice i love that guy
i was watching him before i got famous
and he makes the best slings i've been
looking and he is the best singer
and the best thing maker in the game i
bought some shitty ass slings
on amazon and they fell apart and then i
returned them because
that's what you can do but
yeah these shitty little slings you can
buy on amazon they're [ __ ] you got
to go to practical paracord
and he makes them out of like uh like
this uh bungee jumping or like a [ __ ]
that uh skydiving or symbol some
parachute paracord [ __ ]
and it does not break and you can get
that thing slanging really far but yeah
humans are pretty evil and
terrible but i think that's just because
we're more powerful
i think if other animals got more power
they would do as much evil as we do they
just don't have the ability to
and we just got to be aware of that and
like [ __ ] correct our evilness
we can't just like lean into that and be
like well we're gonna be evil so why
don't we just be evil but in an awesome
way we gotta just be like we we gotta
stop being evil and [ __ ]
conspiracies uh the
was that called the
um
franklin credit scandal where a bunch of
republicans or yeah republicans were
molesting little boys
uh and it's like a big thing in the
republican party and it just got swept
under the rug and people are just
molesting children all the time up there
because it's like
this is a society that's built on
conquest
and uh
winning and just taking and getting
everything you can like why wouldn't we
most children
it's like you're taking from someone
everything and people are just objects
like a country that never fully atoned
for slavery is not going to have the
best attitude towards weak
vulnerable people
they just use them like resources and
just snort children up
i think it's horrible
and i think that uh it's like a very
very bad thing
you know democrats molest
girls little girls republicans molest
little boys
i don't know why i don't i didn't make
the rules that's just how it is the
franklin credit scandal was recently
featured on an episode of chapo trap
house and that's how i heard about it
how come we forgot about epstein already
not the juggalos not the icps
if there's a group of people that have
been epstein it's those people with the
freaky piercings and the pink hair
and that kind of [ __ ]
they have definitely have a lot of
traumatized energies going about with
them
uh bro could you imagine a super smart
gigantic kangaroo we want to stand a
chance
um
well yeah i mean i guess if kangaroos
were really smart what about all the
countries that still have slavery
yeah like libya
like who's afraid of libya
like america did slavery and they were
like good at it
and it became ingrained in part of their
culture and we spread it everywhere
and then we never fully like corrected
that little bug in our culture
i mean the arabic slave trade was bigger
but it wasn't like a huge part of their
identity they were just like of course
we have slaves that is what we do we
love slavery yes oh we don't have slaves
okay that's fine but americans are like
yeah i love
getting free labor [ __ ] yeah
this is what i do i get to do this this
is a part of who i am
and like they internalize that morality
and then i feel like in arabia they were
just like
of course why wouldn't it it wasn't like
something like they tried to justify and
tried to like
[ __ ] make a part of their whole [ __ ]
um
you let tony bully you for wearing a
condom during a bj
yeah i get bullied
i'm the most successfully bullied person
in the world
so
maybe not the world maybe jim norton is
because he he's into that sexually
um what's your opinion on what aboutism
what about
libya what about syria i mean i think
it's uh
it's like
legitimate sometimes when you're like
hey you should stop
you should stop raping children
okay what about you you're raping
children
like if there's a bigger issue at hand
that you'd want to solve rather than
this small issue that someone else
brought up
then i think it's a good way to make an
ad hominem attack to make someone feel
bad to get real change in the world but
if you're trying to talk about this
topic
um then i think it's not that good
um
what about the slaves that work at apple
factories count chocula slave owners
um yeah i mean the
that's a pretty bad slavery that's
happening
you know we don't pay our workers very
well and we
let that happen everywhere
hans kim un
2024
yes an election
for the north korean dictator thanks for
the
whoa 20 canadian so like two american
dollars
music choice probably alternative
probably
uh
bluegrass
probably a lot of stuff
time for a background change
um but uh yeah i mean i love
america i think it's a great country i
think there's a lot of flaws with it and
that is cool because
um then there's a lot more [ __ ] that we
can fix and
it's not just a boring old country where
you like not the netherlands where you
just have to do your little part and
look what i get when i type in americ
america
um
yeah i mean i think it's a great country
i just think that there's a lot of [ __ ]
that we have to do
definitely
um
and that we're responsible for a lot of
[ __ ] in the world
but we didn't know any better
um
desktop
background error
let's go with
i want to take back america from all
those
yahoos and weirdos
this is good
because um like america is associated
with so much bad [ __ ]
um
but uh yeah
i think it's a great country we just
gotta get our [ __ ] together and we're
the only ones that can right now like
you could go to another country and make
them a superpower and then change the
world or you could just deal with the
superpower you have now
and change
that superpower instead of the [ __ ]
making another one
but yeah i mean people like if you don't
love it then leave it but america has
always been about changing and making it
better and improving like if you just
want to
make it the same and
keep doing the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
doesn't work and keep watching people
die and the world the country slide into
poverty that is that's not very american
just be like this is the best we can do
let's just inv like double down on this
and make it nice for the people who
already are here and not worry about
immigrants that's like the opposite of
america
would you ever consider spying aren't
you rogan for the american government as
a civil duty of course no i would i'm on
joe rogan's side over the american
government covet is a psyop
i mean it can be turned into a psyop but
i don't think that
it's infeasible unfees infeasible that a
pandemic would occur in a global scale
because we do live in a very
international world and i think that
there
can be diseases that spread like it's
gonna happen it'll probably happen
another time in the next 200 years at
least and we should probably respond
better to it than we did instead of
being like arguing with each other and
fighting each other we should like
figure out how to
make sure the virus doesn't spread and
doing the both best we can to fix our
[ __ ] what is the backstory of the super
german name
my parents don't want kids at school to
make fun of me for having an asian name
so they're going to be a german one
instead
uh bring back tacos hey do you like
chakruteri boards no i don't really like
charcuterie boards i think charcuterie
boards are like what rich people think
people eat like this is like what an
alien would think human beings eat
and it's just like not real food
it feels like
you know
let's make me a little more less white
that [ __ ] up the background
i gotta be white
for the background
if i'm not white then it turns all
grainy
whiteness what is right
south america is pretty good
yeah
what we did to south america is a sin
and it's very very bad
how do you like the south compared to
the north
um i love the south i love things about
the south i hate the politics of the
south
and uh i love the
you know the weather here is different
it's not cold which is nice but it's can
be more brutal
uh dollar tree will occasionally sell
intimacy lube
okay that was important
for the first chinese president
i talked to so i did a couple man on the
street interviews while i was in chicago
and there was like a lot of chinese
students there and they're terrified to
be talking on camera about china like
apparently
they're scrubbing the internet and if
you say some [ __ ] about china that's not
positive they'll [ __ ] with you in china
like they're
at that level
where they're like censoring
people's speech
which is what they've always been doing
but now with it technology now you have
to be extra careful because everything
is being recorded everywhere
and let's just say that i have footage
on my memory cards that could get a
couple chinese people really [ __ ] up
uh so
you know there's that power it's like
power
it's like you never get the power that
you want it's just some random ass weird
power that you can't really use or
utilize or turn into money
i could extort them be like hey if you
want me to delete this pay me 20 bucks a
month
but then i would be just turning into
china
and i just think that uh you know the
reason why china is like that is because
they are fighting a war they went
through an existential threat with the
japanese occupation and then the
uh chinese civil war between the
communists and the nationalists that was
funded by america and
the opium wars before then the attempted
colonization by britain
and they are scared and they're fighting
they're fighting for their right to live
and so they're it's like if america is
at war like during
the patriot act era during 9 11
like how did we respond we took away
some
powers because 3 000 people died one day
that's all it took for us to get rid of
all your our [ __ ]
uh to get rid of our privacy and data
like now imagine a country that's bigger
than us not just some people in the
caves actively trying to destroy us and
being like they are the enemy we hate
them they are everything we stand for
and not
that actually the opposite of what we
stand for
and they're just fighting a war so they
have to batten down the hatches they
have to be like everyone on board
everyone we're doing this fight fight
fight we're fighting against a thing
and um you know because if they don't do
that america is going to slide right in
slide their little greasy little [ __ ]
into china and start [ __ ] it
and they've had to
resist american rape for a while
but yeah i mean they're fighting against
us they are at war with us and so their
lives are shittier
like we are not even
really fighting a war with them we're
just sort of existing and that's all it
takes for us to be
a threat to the china to the chinese
and they are like full bore like [ __ ]
with us
but from those people love to complain
about the country but have never lived
anywhere else i'll stay here in good old
us rather than move back to mexico
yeah i mean we [ __ ] mexico up thanks
for the
i would i really appreciate that
anyone can love america if you pay me 20
bucks
not everything has to take two minutes
or less 40 billion dollars to love from
australia but yeah i mean they're just
like [ __ ] scared and so they're like
[ __ ] trying to [ __ ]
[ __ ] not die
so that's that's why they are the way
they are
um and if we weren't attacking other
countries and trying to make them more
like us and i think the world would be a
better place
china
china
beautiful
beautiful china
that looks chinese as [ __ ]
china
china
oh we are in china now
i love china
thoughts on abortion and contraptive is
america going backwards yeah this is
what happens if you let conservatives in
charge like oh
we're gonna vote for trump it's gonna be
so funny look all the libs are crying
and now you don't have abortion how
happy are you now [ __ ]
you think this is good this is terrible
terrible
the world that the conservatives want to
create is horrible i know you have fun
like talking giving lip service to
conservative ideas but you would not
want to live in the world that they
create
all the best part
of american
law and policy are liberal legalization
of weed gay marriage uh
you know other other things like that
make your life better you know the five
day work week
weekends
or left-wing policies
i guess guns are cool too
um
but yeah i mean
it's not a very good um
it's not a very good
uh way to run a country is with fear and
protecting a small minority or a
majority of the population of an ethno
majority like that's pretty much
republican politics as they just want to
preserve what we have now which is where
white people are in charge and um you
know like
if you believe in the free market why do
white people need extra protection why
don't you just let the free market
decide
who's the dominant race are you afraid
that you're not gonna have the
skills to be the dominant race so you
need to make
coddling laws that preserve wealth
to win
don't you have confidence in yourself
like
these republicans
are the most racist to white people
because they're like
white people need to have
uh
stop immigration to be in charge because
if we let immigrants in they're gonna
take over because they're better than us
like have some confidence in your
whiteness dude white people are awesome
they can do awesome [ __ ]
and you can still compete with mexicans
like you don't need laws
coddling the rich
who all happen to be white or mostly
white
like you can just let it go and see
who's the best at running a company and
you'll still do pretty good okay
actually asians make the most money in
america you think if asians made the
most money in america
they wouldn't [ __ ] do the chinese
exclusion act part two revenge of the
whites
um
i think that um
i think that asian people are like
[ __ ] crazy
have you heard a german children's story
straight fear
um they would destroy the iconic
legalized robin tug
yeah who do you think is going to
legalize prostitution first republicans
in their religious zealotry or
the democrats who
are sort of weird and [ __ ] i don't care
about abortion i'm a man i don't have
sex lol at hans kim
yeah that's a good funny way to look at
it like oh like why do i care about
abortion i'm not getting laid anyways
you want me to fight for your rights
then [ __ ] me [ __ ]
that's kind of uh
inselly
and i'm actually [ __ ] a [ __ ]
so
can't stand with you you're on your own
[ __ ]
go find a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
anymore i'm part of the late i'm the
upper one percent i'm the one percent of
the one percent i get laid now [ __ ]
all for me none for you don't tax the
people getting laid we don't deserve it
we are getting laid we're awesome
better in some ways
you're generalizing liberals gave
their money to white rich men who are
already rich don't get it twisted yes
the liberals do give all their money to
rich white men the democratic party
these [ __ ] lip service democrats
we believe in
love and equality
okay then give us your money
uh
well you should work for it
[ __ ] you didn't work for it give me
your [ __ ] money your country is
falling apart your life will be better
if you give us money we won't rob you
and you won't have to live in fear and
you can live in an
in a society instead of a jungle
you don't think that there is a level of
too much immigration
yeah there is a level of too much
immigration but it's far above what
republicans want
and why is there immigration because
republicans invaded countries and
destroyed el salvador and had death
squads in nicaragua and
uh
overthrew allende and
our bends
in guatemala
we destroyed latin america for bananas
and
for
drugs
i guess and for whatever and now they're
like all coming over here because this
is where all we stored all their loot
here we got their money they just want
their money back
um but yeah i mean i uh i think that if
you want to stop immigration improve
those countries stop [ __ ] with them
leave them the [ __ ] alone
stop using them as a piggy bank to
extract money out of
and then they'll stop immigrating to
this country where they don't speak the
language where they don't want
to
ingratiate themselves into the culture
they'll stay in their own [ __ ]
countries and have a beautiful nicaragua
with a beautiful nicaraguan
culture instead of having all their like
most successful people come here
destroying their [ __ ]
you know intellectual contributions and
[ __ ]
um
hans are you coming to new orleans
anytime soon new orleans is actually
pretty close to where i am so i could
make the trip pretty easily
if the money's good but i don't know new
orleans isn't really a comedy city it's
not really that big on the comedic arts
they're more good in
at the spookiness ooh
and drinks and partying and boobs and
like
mindless hedonistic pleasures and
you know ghosts and goblins
um oh panama our benz who is in
guatemala
i'll just look this up
guatemala was someone
but yeah we [ __ ] with latin america so
hard and now we don't want to have to
pay for that we're like we got all your
money and we don't want any of the
humanitarian
crisis please
just the bananas
no not the people just bananas
um
hans is
good harambe hombre
oh nice that's spanish
any interest in politics after comedy
i mean if that's if if i'm becoming a
politician you know the world's fallen
to [ __ ]
i mean i would want someone as a
politician who's actually practiced and
well-versed in politics and not someone
who spent 10 years doing open mics
my specialty lies in talking to drunk
people and comedians who don't
want to listen to you
i'm not good at compromising i'm not
good at shaking hands and kissing babies
i'd rather yell at [ __ ] whatever
china
i'm in china
you're gonna take the title of top young
rising comedian
okay
i mean i don't know if it's like a title
i don't know if there's like a belt but
you know there it doesn't have to be one
or the other it's not like a zero-sum
game there's like enough for all of us
at the same time
um
debate david lucas on trump
i mean david lucas is a
very independent black man and i want to
want to infringe on his rights to
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
the us isn't evil it exports united
states dollar hegemony
um
i think that the us
is
confused like there's part of it we're
like yeah we're doing good we're
civilizing uncivilized people
and then that's how we slide our dick in
and then like then we shove our hand our
fist in with the the corporations that
come in later that are like yeah we're
helping you guys
and then they [ __ ]
ram their [ __ ] into the into other
countries through the help of
missionaries and humanitarian aid
and i think it's like disjointed and
like
it's like a perfect symbiosis so that
you don't have to take the moral
responsibility of colonization you can
just be like well we were trying to help
it's just like these other guys got
infected all up
um i didn't see the fights last weekend
it was a fight night i mean i love the
ufc i think it's best if i just watch
the pay per views i almost said the pay
pals
the pay-per-views because like sometimes
i get bored of fighting
i i like it every now and then but i
don't like it too much because
a lot of it is just people bouncing up
and down and
finding their distance and like dodging
[ __ ]
i like
finishes i don't like decisions i know
that makes me a basic [ __ ] i'm just
watching to watch people get [ __ ] up
and die but
what can i say that's what piques my
interest why try to change how i feel
why not just feel my bo most base
emotions with little to no effort to
improve upon it but just be an animal
enjoying the most simple things
late to this wild party how high are you
i'm soberinos i'm completely sober i
have nothing to hide
i will piss into a cup right now to
prove to you that i am
[ __ ] chilling you good homie that's
so passive aggressive you good because
i'm doing better than you
this is how you are
all the time i would hate to be you man
um
you know people that are strong and
confident
they think they're better than people
who are meek and shy but it's way easier
to go through life
confidently it's harder to go through it
thinking about things and questioning
yourself and
listening to other people
like
you think you're brave try being meek
and
kind
donate all the money to them
the candy in the van hey hans who was
the best kisser on kill tony
well i don't know who the best kisser
would be i would say that the one that
sticks in my mind is stormy
just because i think that uh she's a
great person
and beautiful but
i have a girlfriend now so i don't
really think about
my past kisses
i just revel in the beauty of my
girlfriend and her
emotional
safety and you know it's just like
i don't want just random people
who i have short relationships with i
think people who are like that are
emotionally stunted idiots who are
[ __ ]
and like man children i think it takes a
lot more coolness
to uh
be with one person and develop a large
beautiful thing because the gains are
exponential like with just another
person it's just like oh that's just
another addition of positive emotion oh
there's another one and you're just like
building blocks
arithmetically
but with a single person
you can have an exponential uh
relationship where you're getting these
serotonin bumps and
positive emotions that are
way outweighing the amount of effort
that you put in
so i think that's more efficient in
terms of emotional
drugs that you get hans don't get johnny
depp please hans
no
are my eyes big enough now [ __ ]
hey hon just wanted to give you some
love hope you're doing great peace okay
well i have a girlfriend so don't give
me too much love as an argentinian i
think the lack of american pride is sad
well you know
i mean if your country did half the [ __ ]
we did you would not have as much pride
but yeah i mean we overthrew a
uh
democratically elected leader in
argentina too holla
argentina in the house
we [ __ ] with them too as a young book
i only eat some germs from the buckies
have you
bank
the girl cleaning the mic from red rose
i haven't banked her
i've barely even
i barely even got a venmo from her
martial's banked her
yo have you ever watched delore on
youtube
the [ __ ] is a bucky it's a gas station
in texas it's a texas chained gas
station that specializes in
lots of pumps
like 40 pumps
they're like giant rest stops and then
you go inside and they have a bunch of
food it's like a walmart
mixed with a costco
um
i didn't have breakfast yet i'm doing
the intermittent fasting
um amber herd is a national treasure and
must be protected at all costs
have you seen her in aquaman
it's not that good
uh there's plenty of hot girls
we can just replace her with another one
not that valuable
i see plenty of girls hotter than amber
heard
on sixth street let me just grab one of
them
teach them how to read
there you go you got an amber heard
um
sorry i'm from texas i thought that's
what you meant
yeah bucky's not bucky so how much is
gas in texas right now i think like
about four bucks for unleaded
uh then the base price in chicago is
like five bucks
who you like more joe rogan or tony
hinchcliffe and why
that's
not how
life works i mean i don't want to have
one person that i like i like all them
for different reasons and it's not like
a buzzfeed article here are the top
seven people that i like
number one
is
salvador allende
you know it's like everyone adds a
different thing to my life and i try to
collect as many of them as possible and
snort them like a
like cocaine and
use them and abuse them like a resource
no i love humanity and i try to respect
humanity and i don't i try not to treat
people shitty and
use them i try to uh get as much benefit
from them as possible
uh you actually have a dmt pen yeah it's
uh somewhere in here thanks for making
people laugh then that's a lot of texts
bro what the [ __ ] is like 5 50 out of
here and
check out here and
it's like 5 50 out here in chicago yeah
there's a benefit to living in the
oils
the place where we rape the world for
oil this is the center of the place
where
all the rapings happen for oil we all pl
we plan the rapes here in texas for oil
we are playing the oil rapes here in
texas
and there are some benefits to that you
know the rest of the world subsidizes
our low oil costs
and it's pretty [ __ ] dope
you know
we might have giant sprawling highways
where you have to get everywhere by car
but at least we have to pay
less and gas per gallon maybe not
overall because you have to get
everywhere in texas by car you cannot
get anywhere on foot or bike you will
get murdered you will get run over
and nobody will even notice
because they have giant suvs
why would anyone want more government
control when has that ever been good
let's see world war ii world war one
great depression
um
[Music]
911
was government controlled you know
the nhs in england and britain is
government control you know the highways
that
were built
destroying our neighborhoods what's your
mbti type
i don't know what an mbti type is i
don't like that [ __ ] they uh
int vs or whatever and it's just
astrology for [ __ ] liberals
i think that [ __ ] is all [ __ ]
if you want to get to know someone
[ __ ] get to know someone don't make
them take a [ __ ] test in front of you
i think it's just trying to quantify
people and i think that way of thinking
about people is broken and it's like
you're just trying to like [ __ ]
whatever i don't want to be too negative
yeah i don't know what type i am i guess
i'm introverted extroverted also
uh thinking i'm a thinker i don't
i mean i guess i'm whatever i don't know
what i am
what's your thought about people getting
radicalized on the internet like the guy
in buffalo new york i think it's
horrible
what if i was like i fully support it we
should
yeah no that's horrible we've all been
in grocery stores
before um
and we
would all like it if
people at grocery stores weren't
shooting people
um it's just
yeah i mean
like we have to trust each other and we
don't we live in a society where
everyone is fighting with each other and
nobody likes each other and this is what
you get you get people [ __ ] murdering
each other and
i mean
i could never
um
i i don't think i
that's something that anyone should ever
do
but i can see
why that would happen
like if you think that you're the
average mental health in the country
then half the people are worse than that
so if people are struggling and they're
mentally unstable
and they're also young and they don't
know much about the world then
it's like
we don't have a society that really
treats
people's mental health very well we use
and abuse people's mental health for
profit
and when
uh your mental health is being
monetized and [ __ ] with then you're
gonna have
a lot of shitty mental health
um
so yeah i mean
we uh we don't have a a country that
really
takes care of our people and our people
are not taken care of and they're gonna
be all messy and gross and we're gonna
go to a grocery store and be like oh
look at that guy oh girls and they're
gonna be like well it's not a big deal
if i shoot them i hate them anyways so
you know like if we start treating
people better and have like a basement
to have how shitty we're gonna treat
people
then it's gonna be like
we're gonna have less shootings but if
we're like oh it's okay to
shove people out in the street they
don't have money [ __ ] them you know go
starve go develop an ulcer
go have an open wound on your leg yeah
that's normal this is how we treat
people in this country then it's going
to be like well why
why wouldn't i shoot them
well not why would i shoot them but
it wouldn't be a big deal to shoot them
because they're so devalued
i mean we got to value people more
and then they'll
be more valuable to us and then we'll
people will stop being like oh these are
just people that i can shoot
if you treat people as beautiful
beautiful
souls and spirits then it's going to be
harder to shoot them and if we all
indoctrinate people to be like look a
human is worthy and beautiful even if it
doesn't have money like we treat them
really good even though they're not
contributing that much to society right
now they might in the future then we're
going to be like oh maybe i shouldn't
just go into a grocery store and shoot
people they're not just objects maybe
they're they're worth more than whatever
they can give me at the moment
hans where do you prefer to write what
do you do typically use pen and paper
computer
um
so how i typically write is like this
can you hear this this [ __ ] [ __ ]
sometimes doesn't pick up my [ __ ]
but uh yeah um
i um
i write i okay so ideally i try to write
2 000 words every day
and i usually do it on computer so i can
keep track of that [ __ ]
and then i also um
whenever something pops into my head i
make it a habit to [ __ ] write
on my telephone
um
is it possible to change careers at 30
yes you are morally obligated to change
your career at 30 please do not do the
same thing your whole life unless you
really really love it like i do with
comedy you need to do a lot of different
things don't just do one thing with your
life like a [ __ ] giraffe you're meant
for more than that you're meant to
pursue your hobbies and passions no
matter where they take you and your life
should be lived around that and not
around having
uh stability and safety like a like a
[ __ ] cow
take a risk even though in this country
we don't treat people who fall out of
the system very well
it's gonna be hard
but you should do it um
uh
hans are you actually on the spectrum
ever been diagnosed or talked to a
doctor about it what the [ __ ] you think
i would go to the system the society
that has
churned and burned so many people and be
like please fix me let me be more
something that you approve of i would
love to do what
is your
diagnosis [ __ ] these people they don't
know what the [ __ ] to do with people
they will just drug me up and put me in
a cubicle
do not trust these people who have
produced the most mental health
illnesses in the world to fix your
mental health the solution lies in the
organic and the uh things that we have
done for centuries
the answer to humanity does not lie in
more
uh
analytical approach but a more
um you know like
you know doing uh doing what we've been
doing for centuries and millennia and
[ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] diagnoses and
oh you're on uh the dsm [ __ ] the dsm
they haven't made significant strides
since it came out like there's more
mental health issues now because people
are poor
if people are poor it doesn't matter how
many [ __ ] pills you shove in their
[ __ ]
concert have you
watched everything everywhere all at
once what did you think i have watched
everything everywhere all at once and i
thought it was
i mean
it was fine
it's like beautiful and it's cool it's
like the multiverse everything's a
[ __ ] multiverse now everything's
happening in different like
this is what happens if you don't have
good public education is people take
these bits of pop science and just
this is like the only thing that we
understand now is
the multiverse
um but yeah i mean i thought the
multiverse concept was a little
convoluted i like to just stay in one
universe please i'm not used to jumping
universes maybe i'm just too
1990s brained but i
i like one universe
i don't like just popping into another
universe just to visit it's so
schizophrenic and it doesn't make a
coherent story
um
um
[Music]
yeah i mean
i think the uh
the thing is like
i uh i think it was a great allegory for
the generational struggle
like
in the movie spoiler alert the grandpa
disowns the uh the gen xer the boomer
disowns a gen xer she moves to america
she has a child a millennial the
millennial has a superpower that she can
use and it's amazing and she's crazy
good at
multiversing and then the
gen xer is just like confused she's
stuck in the middle between this old
[ __ ] and this new [ __ ]
and it's like
totally not taking responsibility for
any of the [ __ ] that they let happen
2 000 words just anything
i just write whatever it takes because
it's hard enough i don't want to like
constrain myself
but yeah whatever pops into your head
and that is what you should be talking
about whatever pops into your head
naturally is what you're interested in
don't try to change that don't try to
think in a different way just think more
better in the way that you already think
don't be like oh what would a
normal
suburban housewife think of this that i
wrote i should think more like her and
that way i'll have comedy that she likes
she doesn't want
to see your version of her she's already
herself she doesn't need more her and a
shitty version of it that's not
authentic
she needs your authentic version of
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
and that way she can borrow from
whatever you happen to be bringing to
the
table
and the world can learn more from you
being yourself and exactly what you
think and whatever you want to do
hey bro i'm working on some material and
going to my first time on a local open
mic next week
i got funny concepts but my delivery is
clunky as [ __ ]
any tips
um
have less confidence in your funny
concepts and more confidence in your
delivery
um
[Music]
yeah i mean everyone thinks their
concepts are funny
and everyone thinks that oh it's just my
delivery that sucks but i mean you're a
human being and you possess
hands and eyes and mouths and that's
inherently empathetic it triggers our
empathy in mirror neurons and so you
have the bare minimum to
elicit an emotional response so
um you know
you know the ideas are
important but it's like
it's like how you elicit the ideas and
how you how you uh do that [ __ ] so
figure it out and play around with it
and have a good time how could you
convince tony to bring the kill tony
crew to maryland well once maryland gets
a
major metropolis then i think it'll be
easy to convince him
as long as your
biggest city is bought baltimore it's
going to be a little difficult to get
over there maybe invest in your public
infrastructure
maybe stop torturing black people and
shooting them for running away
maybe
replace your entire police force with a
new one
that isn't terrorizing its citizens and
is an occupying army maybe provide
economic
opportunities to those in your
uh
poverty-stricken communities
and improve everyone everywhere all at
the same time
um
but yeah everything everywhere all at
once i thought was a great allegory and
very beautifully uh
told story about how the gen xers feel
about the world that they created
through complacency
and uh
weren't smart enough to
stage a revolution in and
think more
uh
dangerously
like what are we to do we had all the
power we let it slip through our fingers
and now we're letting the boomers rape
our millennial children
it's your fault take some [ __ ]
responsibility don't just stand there
like what was i supposed to do [ __ ]
you did this [ __ ] too
um
but yeah i mean
um like
i get that their their point is like we
came from something crazy and we created
something crazy and we're just in the
middle just watching this [ __ ]
um and you know like have some more
faith in millennials and have some more
uh empathy for the boomers
but uh yeah i mean
i think it was a great movie
in terms of whatever
i think the visuals i guess
i like the story i mean i like the
husband
he's got a squeaky little voice
i love the idea of multiple lives and
[ __ ]
um
[Music]
what's your take on tony chin band
the tony chin band i support the tony
chin band
the
are you ever going to have a podcast
hans
i thought that's what this was
i thought i was on a podcast
this is my podcast you want me to talk
to someone else who's just going to
interrupt me all the time
yeah why don't we have nonsense
trains of thought that i can't control i
have legionnaires disease
okay
good luck
hopefully you find a legion and you can
become a
a part of a legion so that you can have
someone to commiserate with about your
legionnaire's disease
i lost some money and now i have to
borrow some from my wife's boyfriend
so your wife is suck [ __ ] someone
else yeah you should any advice you
should be charging a fee to [ __ ] your
wife you should be like this is
patronage this is your
dues i need money if you want to [ __ ] my
wife
who's the standout that makes you laugh
the hardest man
who makes you laugh the hardest man
i am the hardest man
i get pretty hard uh who's the standout
that makes you laugh the hardest man
i mean shane gillis is like technically
amazing
and i respect him fully but um i really
don't laugh at stand up
i usually get really jealous or really
cringed out it's
not very easy for me to watch comedy i'm
always thinking oh [ __ ] this guy is
doing things i could never do or i'm
thinking wow
this guy is awful and i hate him and
he's a hack and he doesn't deserve to
live and i want to [ __ ] on his
wife
shout out from san antone looking
forward to smoking a weed with you again
just one weed
i love to smoke multiple weeds with my
buddies has rogan stand up
rogan is an amazing stand-up he's one of
the best in the world and i think that
he is uh he is going to explode
with his newest special
i think that um
i think that uh
people are
don't uh
don't give him the credit he deserves
uh the mao at the cuck tax i'm pimping
my aunt
and grandma like i mean i know this
guy's embarrassed that he has to like
give money to get money because he lost
money from his wife's boyfriend but it's
better than
having a wife's boyfriend
[ __ ] your wife for free at least now
you're getting money from him if there's
an option between getting money from my
wife's boyfriend and him [ __ ] or him
just [ __ ] hurt well at least you're
[ __ ] him now kind of
uh thoughts on louis ck
i think he's a great comedian i think
that maybe he's sort of like a a weird
dude
i don't think that he's always like
the most morally
uh
correct but i don't think that he's the
most reprehensible morally i think that
he is a horny dude and i think women uh
they lash out on targets that are easy
and not necessarily the targets that
deserve their scorn
and i think louis was just a convenient
target like if you're like a
soft nice little boy then they're gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] on you worse than like a
rapist who's like a horrible person with
a lot of power like they'd rather like
go for the easy targets than like
someone who actually deserves it and
will actually bring about real change so
they attack whoever the [ __ ] they can
the targets that are available and i
don't think it's a woman thing i think
it's like
a subjugated person's thing i think a
lot of people do that and it's gross and
it's shitty
i will be with rogan at detroit in
detroit this week as long as i don't get
cancelled
um
and when is big hans gonna get a special
when i've been practicing and doing a
lot of
hour long sets and con constructing an
hour together
um but i've been doing an hour 15 it's 4
pm i should get on with my day and this
has been a lot of fun i'll probably do
it again more regularly i want to do
this a lot more and stuff
um but yeah i love uh doing these solo
podcasts i like them doing i like doing
this more than with someone else
honestly because i don't have to be like
oh do they hate me do they think i'm
awkward do they think i'm weird like
this is like my preferred way to do it
and just talk in a chat because they
give me stuff to talk about
and maybe i could like watch videos or
some [ __ ] but i feel like that would
take away from me talking i know i don't
want to just be watching things on
camera but yeah this has been a green
screen the whole time i'm not even in
china
i am in oh like old
look at this china
open image in new tab
oh look at me i'm in china painting
um but yeah i'm just hanging out having
a good time and um i enjoy these
hopefully i can clip some of this if
anyone wants to clip this please do
i would love it oh [ __ ] you can see the
shitty green screen
i'll show you the green screen is the
clipping part i have not been doing at
all and i've really been slacking so if
anyone would like to clip it i'd pay you
uh just clip it please
hans how many women have you been with
probably like 50
maybe 60.
all right
thanks for